man you know my name with two R's Oh
that I know loss of point Avery
Williamson Darren Lee speedy linebackers
for the Jets and we're gonna kick their
ass what's up better see they're just
taking it I don't know what to say right
now
feeling confident very yeah I like how
you guys eager like I knew my daughter
in college I'll shake others on the
count of three - no it's some stupid
name
yes I'm going with this hometown and
putting a prep on the ends like a TV
show what did you do last year its
multi-day Wow damn you had a bad year
for hitting Jay Cutler actually oh my
god yeah both both of them actually on
Jay and both up over on Joy $66,000
that's the nice Mercedes you just lost
Hank I know you did better off hitting
him with a Mercedes man I do know this
yeah because he has a big mouth but I
heard him telling everybody in the
office they saw it on my Instagram well
like you know I don't go there
I'm ready oh that's different
best looking at most beautifully on the
only one that believes rules it's so
Nash Nash Ville was having a battle in
here huh hold on a second if he doesn't
get this right oh my god I got it we've
gone through this repeat it seems like
it's around here you seemed like a
December guys you seem like a former
friend you got a wrong oh you want to
know what's even worse tell them is I
asked him what his birthday was before
we came in here yeah I was gone I could
they might ask me again is weird so I'll
come to move yes to go okay
I put it down is it not preacher in the
middle uh-huh yep no other way hold on
hold on
yeah yeah yeah catch the ball no
I gave them good eye my hands were in
your that's good they're clean into the
hoop left coast legs cannot move but his
arm appears I'm nervous
I don't know where this is going alright
here's the first one
oh oh oh oh oh he moved my feet
that's all right your books a table your
feet Oh nicely done
I'm the calvin johnson of Hulagu plains
no ah
I found the touch watch out
Oh Joe Oh nobody comes into our house
Oh four to five good luck way to find
your touch accent
[Music]
you can probably do it sir probably look
at the loggers arms are you switching
nice and easy
oh god right here oh oh there you go you
got enough we got it yes oh my god was
it what money you're supposed to be a
meat head linebacker you're not supposed
to be able to do this
always getting kaka point what's up are
you kidding
[Music]
let's go I thought you had it
[Music]
Lego great job today's winners are Avery
Williamson and Darren Lee and as you can
tell boy are they humble they are humble
[Music]